Position would be would be that,
okay,
you should try to become aware of the
totality of your subjective experience,
so not only do you feel it in an
embodied sense,
but that you represented at a that you
represented and the representation would
be mostly in terms of articulation.
It isn't clear that Roger is considered
other forms of representation,
but
Roger's the movement towards health is
an integrative process and it's very
body focused,
but the outcome of that integrative
process which Rogers would say is the
ability to live the good life is that
your language is no longer instrumental.
What you're doing instead is attempting
to state the truth as you see it because
of course your truth is a partial truth.
Obviously the basket you can do is,
well,
I really think the best you can do is
not live if you can't tell the truth
because you're too damn stupid,
right?
You don't know enough to tell the truth,
but you can certainly do your best to
represent what you know is clearly as
you possibly can in your communication
with other people.
And so rogers believed that it was the
moral responsibility of the therapist to
do that personally and then to the
degree that that was being done in the
therapy and the therapy
relationship in the therapeutic
relationship,
that that in and of itself would be
healing.
And so basically Roger's theory is that
honest communication heels.
No,
you know,
that's quite an interesting theory.
No,
it's not.
It's not completely unaligned from
Freud's earlier claims,
right?
Because Freud
basically presumed that it was.
I didn't put so much of a moral element
on it.
He really viewed the person more as as
being trapped between titanic opposing
forces,
the IED underneath and the superego and
top important illegals are crunched up
in the middle and as a consequence of
being pulled and product and crushed by
those titanic forces,
pathology was likely to emerge and he
talked about repression,
but for tended to view repression as an
unconscious process for for Rogers,
the moral element of the therapeutic
process is much clearer,
I believe,
and most of the time when you listen to
Rogers or you read what he had to say,
the injunctions that he's laying out or
moral injunctions.
Now,
it's quite interesting because you don't
necessarily think of psychotherapy as a
moral endeavor and I really never
thought about it that way fully until I
read.
I was reading Rogers at the same time,
but you don't tow weight out the
proposition in this book that most of
the problems,
many of the problems that people came to
see a therapist about,
we're actually moral problems and they
were moral problems of various sorts.
Now sometimes the person was in trouble
because they had done something
seriously,
seriously wrong.
He had one client,
if I remember correctly,
and he discovered,
that she had killed her children and she
did that when they were young.
She had them.
She let them become exposed to
tuberculosis.
I think it was.
She didn't take the proper precautions
and the reason she did that was because
she wanted to marry someone and he
wasn't very interested in her children.
So you might consider that a moral
problem on your.
Apparently
apparently it was weighing on her
conscience,
you know,
as it might.
Well now it's a strange thing because in
some sense what she did was turn a blind
eye to something she could have
prevented it in legal terms that's known
as willful blindness,
but she knew whatever that means.
Well,
there's lots of different levels of
knowing,
right?
You can know something in your body,
you can know something in your
imagination.
You can know something in articulated
form,
you know,
so the whole issue of knowing is a very
complicated.
But Rogers
definitely believed as far as I can
tell,
that
there was a moral dimension to life that
it was identifiable.
That in some sense,
it was linear that had had an observable
process,
which was the continual integration of
experience within the phenomenal field,
the ironing out of contradictions within
the phenomenal field.